i need to calm down get my heart rate
below 100
a mission accomplished
next game
oh i'm playing uh backwards magnus
carlsen
backwards magnus carlson official
the mysterious national master
oh thanks for being here xy sparks
appreciate you stopping by
also thank you for the
[Music]
50 months of subscribing
[Music]
really appreciate it
okay another london
oh my opponent's from norway
maybe
uh the time control is three plus one
it's actually kind of funny i'm
following a magnus carlsen game
this is the first video in my london
course
exclamation point london
this is carlson beauceoc
and we're still following the game
that game featured bishop takes g3
magnus took back the improvement is
queen takes d8 it did allow this which
would uh also be good for white
um so we've transposed back into the
magnus game
and in this position magnus's opponent
played f5
and then magnus played c6
and now it's completely winning for
white
and this is why you should
study your magnus carlsen games
and also buy my london course
i think we're still following the game
too
like the strategy here is to just get a
monster knight on e5
and then keep the pawn defended
i think in that game magnus went for
some eventual
queenside storm
uh bishop b5 is intentional
so now this is the first moment in the
game i kind of have to
use my brain
[Music]
i think c4
and then like
c5
c5 b4
i wonder if i can play b4 it takes and
then a4 that would be kind of funny
i just want to trap the bishop
rook d5 f4
yeah the monster knight is uh
it is going to last forever on e5
probably b5
and the bishop just stuck on c8
king can consume the pawn
um
[Music]
looking at rook b1 king e7 a5 king d6
b6
need to take the pawn
this plan is uh
kind of hard to stop
after this game i'll show the carlson
beauceoc game and show how similar the
um
the positions are
okay
that was feel good
let me find this game
i think the easiest thing to do is just
copy pgn
open the chest analysis board
and then
paste it in
make sure people can see properly
okay so this is the game i just played
got some nice explanation on the side
and then if we zoom ahead
we can see
oh carlson actually played this twice
but uh
yeah the game we followed was this one
open this new tab
and
yeah had the same position
wait
so the first 20 moves
wait kept
going is this a carlson game
wait
this is exactly the carlson game this is
exactly what i did
i played c4 and then b4
i actually didn't remember this part but
i found the same idea
when did both yochich resign rick dia
king c2
that's so funny bo seochet resigned in
this position
so i played the first 25 moves of my
game
exactly like magnus carlsen
and my opponent played exactly like bose
yochich
who's like a 2600 rated gm
and that's so funny my opponent's
biplone's username
is uh
i'd love to try and pronounce this uh as
it's spelled but it's magnus carlson
official
uh spelled backwards
yeah hello youtube
[Music]
what do i title the youtube video
i played like magnus carlson
and that has multiple meanings it means
i played the same moves as magnus but i
also played an opponent that's like
magnus but not quite
yeah i haven't promoted my london course
in a while but uh
it's in the description of every youtube
video
thank you pubic synthesis